good afternoon my name is Michael Smith
I'm the executive director of the my
brother's keeper Alliance at the Obama
Foundation thank you all for joining us
for this critical and important
conversation today the killings of
George Floyd Brianna Taylor Ahmad Aubrey
and a loss of far too many black lives
two lists have left our nation English
tan outraged
more than a thousand people are killed
by police every year in America and
black people are three times more likely
to be killed than white people we can
take steps and make reforms to combat
police violence and systemic racism
within law enforcement together we can
work to redefine Public Safety so that
it recognizes the humanity and the
dignity of every person this town hall
that we're having today is a part of an
ongoing my brother's keeper Alliance
town-hall series my brother's keeper was
launched by President Obama in 2014
after the tragic killing of Trayvon
Martin the president launched it in the
East Room of the White House calling on
America and everybody to do whatever
they could in their power to make sure
young men of color knew that they matter
and to reduce the systemic barriers that
stand in their way and make sure every
young person has every opportunity to
reach their dreams today the work of my
brother's keeper continues as the my
brother's keeper Alliance at the Obama
foundation where we lead a network of
more than 250 communities and a massive
call to action to businesses mayors and
other folks and communities across the
country our mission is to build safe and
supportive communities where boys and
young men of color are valued and have
clear pathways to opportunity we're
excited to have President Obama sharing
his viewpoints today but also gathered a
panel of local and national experts who
are fighting on the ground and who have
been fighting this fight for many years
before we start our program today I want
to acknowledge the lives of George of
Brianna of Ahmad and far too many others
by taking a 30 minute second 30 minute
30 second moment of silence in order to
remember those lives and reflect please
join me in a moment of silence
you
thank you we speak their names we hold
them in my heart and it is with their
memories that we move ahead in action it
is now my pleasure to start where we
should always start with the future with
a young man that I had the pleasure to
meet when we were at the my brother's
keeper
Ohio Conference where there's an
incredible statewide network of my
brother's keeper in Ohio this young man
played on Patrick blew us away with his
incredible words play on graduated from
Fort Hayes High School in Columbus Ohio
in May class of 2020 he was a straight-a
student member of the National Honor
Society and a student council Patrick
will attend the Ohio State University in
the fall and plans to major in criminal
justice and criminology it is my
pleasure to introduce this brilliant
bright young man our future play on
Patrick hello ladies and gentlemen my
name is plant Patrick I am 18 years old
and plan to attend V Ohio State
University and this is 2020 quarantine
killings and they ask how do black boys
write about their city how do we know
Street if we don't know uncracked
sidewalk they ask how do these black
boys know anything about their city how
the buildings are sitting on corners
where brother's bodies are still
learning how to rot there are small
crosses placed in the grass where
families cannot afford to bury their
loved ones reminds my brothers and I
that we are early graves before we are
anything else we call those corners
playgrounds we call those corners the
killing fields we call our bodies
bullets even if we were never aimed in
the right direction we called the
remnants of our mother's family that I
asked for a tree we make a catalogue of
players out of broken hands we pray for
our family tree to make its way back
home to this soil we use our hands to
dig the graves we cannot afford we
farmers are broken blackbodies we have
never known city never known comfort
never known safe Street in any city we
use our feet to walk streets paid by
sunlight and asked our shadows if they
meant to choose this skin we make a
catalyst a body's our dinner menu and we
eat with our eyes closed we're fed lies
so easily it tastes like medicine always
conflicted between being black and being
people I wish God could have given us a
choice for years we have been told that
there is something we need to scrub off
this body as if this dirt could go away
working in the field make you realize
how easily black and cook in the Sun I
easily return on each other for a little
slice of the pie we don't know this city
how it was built with our grandmother's
arthritic hands I wouldn't have gotten a
house or a Bedouin was first built when
it was first settled when I was first
taken from the Indians but our gods will
lead in the same beginning we don't know
home we know how generations or our
people could use these legs could run
miles on in into the night
our face is bedazzled with the remnants
of the stars we will forever search for
our forefathers footsteps we don't know
home we know run we know this land has
never been ours we know how to fold
ourselves into nothing we know our sweat
and tears tenderize this soil somehow we
make fertilizer for the soul we know how
to make these hand be useful where are
the farmers of every revolution no
country was built without the pounding
up of dead bodies this country just
happens to be wrong dead were dragged
and hung up America the land of the free
and home of the brave we fought and died
for that slogan right beside our white
brothers it doesn't that make us worth
something tonight a riot is the language
of the unheard
I want to take a second to thank the MBK
village and the Obama Foundation for
giving me such a great opportunity to
continue spread the message now it is my
honor to introduce to you a man who
needs no introduction he is the founder
of the my brothers keepers program he is
a father lawyer lecturer community
organizer and so much more
born and raised in Honolulu Hawaii he is
the man who changed America forever it
is none other than the 44th President of
the United States of America President
Barack Obama man thank you well that was
unbelievable and we could not be prouder
and you are a hard act to follow so you
know I can't wait to see all the great
things that you're going to be doing in
the future
good afternoon everybody all the
participants all the panelists you know
let me start by just acknowledging that
we have seen in the last several weeks
last few months the kinds of epic
changes and events in our country that
are as profound as anything that I've
seen in my lifetime and I'm now a lot
older than planned I'm gonna be 59 so
and and let me begin by acknowledging
that although all of us have been
feeling pain uncertainty disruption some
folks have been feeling it more than
others most of all the pain that's been
experienced by the families of George
and Briana and Ahmad and Tony and Sean
and too many others to mention those
that we thought about during that moment
of silence and to those families who've
been directly affected by tragedy
please know that Michelle and I and the
nation grieve with you hold you in our
prayers were committed to the fight of
creating a more just nation and memory
of your sons and daughters and we can't
forget but even as we're confronting the
particular acts of violence that led to
those losses our nation in the world is
still in the midst of a global pandemic
that's exposed the vulnerabilities of
our health care system but also the
disparate treatment and as a consequence
the disparate impact that exists in our
healthcare system the unequal investment
the biases that have led to a
disproportionate number of infections
and loss of life in communities of color
so in a lot of ways what has happened
over the last several weeks is
challenges and structural problems here
in the United States have been thrown
into high relief there the outcomes not
just of the immediate moments in time
but they're the result of a long history
of slavery Jim Crow and redlining in
institutionalized racism that too often
have been the plague this original sin
of our society and in some ways as
tragic as these past few weeks have been
as difficult and scary and uncertain as
they've been they've also been an
incredible opportunity for people to be
awakened to some of these underlying
trends
and they offer an opportunity for us to
all work together to tackle them to take
them up to change America and make it
live up to its highest ideals and part
of what's made me so hopeful is the fact
that so many young people have been
galvanized and activated and motivated
and mobilized because historically so
much of the progress that we've made in
our society has been because of young
people dr. King was a young man when he
got involved
Cesar Chavez was a young man Malcolm X
was a young man that the leaders of the
feminist movement were were young people
leaders of Union movements were were
young people the leaders of the
environmental movement in this country
and the movement to make sure that the
LGBT community finally had a voice and
was represented were young people and so
when I want when when sometimes I feel
despair I just see what's happening with
young people all across the country and
the talent and the voice and the
sophistication that they're displaying
and it makes me feel optimistic it makes
me feel as if you know this country's
don't get better now I want to speak
directly to the young men and women of
color in this country who as plan just
so eloquently described they have
witnessed too much violence and too much
debt and too often some of that violence
has come from folks who were supposed to
be serving and protecting you I want you
to know that you matter I want you to
know that your lives matter that your
dreams matter and when I go home and I
look at the faces of my daughter Sasha
and Malia and I look at my nephews and
nieces I see limitless potential that
deserves to flourish and thrive
and you should be able to learn and make
mistakes and live a life of joy without
having to worry about what's gonna
happen when you walk to the store or go
for a jogger are driving down the street
or looking at some birds in apartment
and and and so I hope that you also feel
helped hopeful even as you may feel
angry because you have the power to make
things better and you have helped to
make the entire country feel as if this
is something that's got to change you've
communicated a sense of urgency that is
as powerful and as transformative as
anything that I've seen in recent years
I want to acknowledge the folks in law
enforcement that share the goals of
reimagining police's because there are
folks out there who took the oath to
serve your communities in your countries
have a tough job and I know you're just
as outraged about tragedies in recent
weeks as our many of the protesters and
so we're grateful for the vast majority
of you who protect and serve I've been
heartened to see those in law
enforcement who recognized
let me March along with these protesters
let me stand side-by-side and recognize
that I want to be part of the solution
and who've shown restraint and
volunteered and engaged and listened
because you're a vital part of the
conversation and and change is going to
require everybody's participation now
when I was in office as was mentioned I
created a task force on 21st century
police policing in the wake of the
tragic killing of Michael Brown that
taskforce which included law enforcement
and community leaders and activists was
charged to develop a very specific set
of recommendations to strengthen public
trust and foster better working
relationships between law enforcement
and communities that they're supposed to
protect
even as they're continuing to promote
effective crime reduction and and that
report showcased a range of solutions
and and strategies that were proven them
that were based on data and research to
improve community policing and collect
better data and reporting and and
identify and and do something about
implicit bias and how police were
trained and and reforms to use the force
the police deploy in ways that increase
sync rather than precipitate tragedy and
that report demonstrated something
that's critical for us today
most of the reforms that are needed to
prevent the type of violence and
injustice that we've seen take places
below below now reform has to take place
in more than 19,000 American
municipalities more than 18,000 local
enforcement jurisdictions and so as
activist and everyday citizens raise
their voices we need to be clear about
where change is going to happen and how
we can bring about that change
it is mayors and county executives that
appoint most police chiefs and negotiate
collective bargaining agreements with
police units and that determines police
practices in local communities its
district attorneys and state's attorneys
that decide typically whether or not to
investigate and ultimately charging
those involved in police misconduct and
those are all elected positions and in
some places they're police community
review boards with the power to monitor
police conduct those times may be
elected as well that the bottom line is
I've been hearing a little bit of
chatter in the internet about voting
versus protest politics and and
participation versus civil disobedience
and direct action this is not a
either/or this is a both and to bring
about real change
we both have to highlight a problem and
make people in power uncomfortable but
we also have to translate that into
practical solutions and laws that can be
implemented and we can monitor and make
sure we're following up on so very
quickly let me just close by with a
couple of specific things what can we do
number one we know there are specific
evidence-based reforms that if we put in
place today would build trust save lives
would not show an increase in crime
those are included in the 21st century
policing task force report you can find
it on Obama door number two a lot of
Mayors and local elected officials read
and supported the task force report but
then there wasn't enough follow so today
I am urging every mayor in this country
to review your use of force policies
with members of your community and
commit to report on planned reforms what
are the specific steps you can take and
I should add by the way that the
original task force report was done
several years ago since that time we've
actually collected data in part because
we implemented some of these reform
ideas so we now have more information
and more data as to what works and there
are organizations like campaign zero and
Color of Change in others that are out
there highlighting the what the data
shows what works what doesn't in terms
of reducing incidents of police
misconduct and violence let's go ahead
and start implementing those so we need
mayor's County executives others who are
positions of power to say this is a
priority this is a specific response
number three every city in this country
should be a my brother's keeper
community because we have 250 cities
counties tribal nations who are working
to reduce the barriers and expand
opportunity for boys and young men of
color the programs and policy reforms
and public/private partners
so go to our website get working with
that because it can make a difference
and let me just close by saying this
I've heard some people say that you have
a pandemic then you have these protests
this reminds people of the 60s and the
chaos and discord and distrust
throughout the country I have to tell
you although I was very young when you
had riots and protests and and
assassinations and discord back in the
60s I know enough about that history to
say there is something different here
you look at those protests and that was
a far more representative cross-section
of America out on the streets peacefully
protesting and who felt moved to do
something because of being justices that
they had seen that didn't exist back in
the 1960s that kind of broad coalition
the fact that recent surveys have showed
that despite some protests having been
been marred by the actions of some a
tiny minority that engaged in in
violence that despite you know as usual
that got a lot of attention a lot of
focus despite all that a majority of
Americans still think those protests
were justified and wouldn't have existed
30 40 50 years ago there is a change in
mindset that's taking place a greater
recognition that we can do better and
that is not as a consequence of speeches
by politicians that's not the result of
you know spotlights in news articles
that's a direct result of the activities
and organizing and mobilization and
engagement
of so many young people across the
country who put themselves out on the
line to make a difference and so I just
have to say thank you to them and for
helping to bring about this moment and
just make sure that we now follow
through because at some point you know
attention moves away at some point
protests start to dwindle in size and
it's very important for us to take the
momentum that has been created as a
society as a country and say let's use
this to finally have an impact all right
thank you everybody proud of you guys
and I know that we're gonna be hearing
from a bunch of people who have been on
the front lines on this and know a lot
more than I do about it
Bradley Thank You mr. president for
everyone that's watching the president
decided he wanted to stay and be a part
of the conversation that's gonna be led
by Brittany Pat net Cunningham with the
Attorney General and other leaders
before we go into that section I want to
reiterate the pledge that the president
mentioned for mayors so if you are mayor
you can go to Obama org and you can take
this pledge and I also want to announce
that several mayor's have said sign me
up first and they have already taken the
pledge mayor de Blasio of New York Mayor
lightfoot of Chicago mayor fray of
Minneapolis Mayor Bowser of DC mayor
breed of San Francisco and their Keshia
Lance bottoms of Atlanta all my
brother's keeper communities as well so
if you go to that page you can take the
pledge and we will be posting all the
cities and all the mayors that take the
pledge and then in 90 days we are gonna
publicly report out who has taken the
pledge in the work that's happening to
create real lasting change in
communities so it is now my pleasure to
introduce a friend an activist and
educator a writer on NBC and MSNBC News
contributor a lifelong activist and
member of the Ferguson uprising a
co-founder of campaign zero a policy
platform to end police violence and
co-host of pods saved the people
previously she was an appointed member
of the Ferguson Commission and president
Obama's Task Force on 21st century
policing today campaign zero of which
Britney as a co-founder launched the
campaign
hashtag eight can't wait an advocacy
campaign to push mayor's across America
to adopt eight use of force policies
that together can reduce police violence
by upwards of seventy percent because to
moderate this conversation with
President Obama and our other incredible
leaders
please welcome Britney PAC MIT
Cunningham thank you so much Frankel and
thank you President Obama for gathering
this conversation in this moment of
intense grief but hopefully intense
purpose we are here together to talk to
have a family conversation you may be
watching this and have come here because
you are experiencing that grief and you
need some community in which to do that
and you're hoping that we can hold you
up to the light you may be here because
like me you are girded in the strength
of your ancestry and you know you come
from people just like I do
who did far more with far less and are
sure that we can win in this moment and
every one after it however you who have
come your way you have come here we're
glad that you're here because we're here
to get honest to get clear most
importantly to get to work so that even
the heartening moments of seeing you
people raise their voices or even in the
moments where a police officer might
take a knee that that momentary action
might turn into true systemic and
lasting change we have so many brilliant
voices that have been gathered and as we
listen to the guests we'll all be able
to better understand how we got to this
moment and how we seize our own power to
get through it
before we get started like Michael I
want to make sure to lift up the names
of the people who brought us here
because it wasn't just the former
president though were deeply grateful it
was George Floyd a father in Minneapolis
it was Brianna Taylor a life-saving EMT
on the frontlines in Louisville it was
shot on Reid a friend and a brother in
Indianapolis it was Tony McDaniel a
black trans man who loved life in
Tallahassee Florida and though it wasn't
from an officer's bullet we are
having this conversation of course in
the shadow of a Mart augury a son from
Georgia and Nina pop and Ayane Dior two
black trans women who were killed assist
hatred that comes against
intersectionally marginalized people in
this country every single day frankly
there are too many names to list because
as the president has already said we
have been at this unfortunately for a
long time so that means that there is
indeed work to do and now we're gonna
get to do it Oh Attorney General Holder
I actually want to start with you
I was raised always to be an activist so
frankly if you ask my mom this is the
only life I've ever known but I came
into the work specifically of fighting
against the surge of violence as it
relates especially to systemic racism in
2014 when Mike Brown was killed in
Ferguson Missouri just a few minutes
from my own home and you came to
Ferguson and as you know there were
thousands literally thousands of brave
and mighty protestors just like the ones
we're seeing outside right now those
protest organizers were on the ground
Lee for change and making the entire
world pay attention I want to know what
you learned from those grassroots
activists what have you carried from
those conversations in Ferguson with you
through to the work that you then and
that you're doing now yeah well it's
good to see you again and thank you
President Obama for convening us here
today you know I remember back in 2014 I
remember meeting with the president we
were on vacation and talking about
whether or not I should go to Ferguson
it was a risky thing didn't know exactly
how people would react to my presence
but we made the determination that I
would go and I think the thing that
struck me the most was there were a few
things that really got me I mean there
were young people who were there and who
were unbelievably impressive who were in
a lot of ways directing the actions that
you saw on the streets you saw a
community that was in anguish and there
was a commonality with regard to the
things that they were concerned about I
was really struck by the fact that
people consistently talked about the way
in which people of color were unfairly
treated by the criminal justice system
and there was a genuine desire by people
to make things better it wasn't all
about just complaining there was a
genuine desire to work to make things
better and I left there actually
heartened but what I saw both in terms
of the reaction that I got people were
extremely respectful and I thought we
had good dialogues while I was there but
also left with the notion that if we
invested some time if we invested some
federal resources that we would be in a
position using the great leaders that we
met that those young people who we met
there to make life in Ferguson better
and then use that as an example of what
was possible in the in the rest of the
country so as the president reminded us
this is not about an either/or question
one of my favorite things to remind
people as President Obama has already
done is this is not about policy or
protest this is about policy and protest
and we know as dr. King and so many
others throughout history taught us is
that protest is actually what creates
the pressure so that the policy can get
passed similarly we are in a long-term
game and a short-term game here that
while we are dealing with radical
imagination and reimagining what public
safety can look like even beyond police
in our communities we have to make sure
that people are safe now your role as
Attorney General you did a lot of that
work in addressing people safety right
now so can you tell us what you learned
that was instructive for this moment
particularly as you engaged in pattern
and practice investigations and consent
decrees once it's situations like this
happened in communities and once we saw
the kind of uprisings that we did all
over the country when you were still in
office well I think one of the key
things that people have to understand is
that there's not a tension between
justice and having fair treatment and
public safety you can keep people safe
and also have a better more equitable on
criminal justice system I mean you know
we
I'm not gonna get too boastful here but
you know for the first time in 40 years
during the Obama administration we
reduced the number of people who are
incarcerated in the federal system and
also lowered the crime rate again there
is not that tension you can make things
better in terms of community and police
relationships and keep people safe at
the same time and so what we tried to do
was come up with ways in which we could
look at what we what we thought were the
the problems in the criminal justice
system and with regard to how policing
was done address those involve the
community in those efforts engage law
enforcement in those efforts bring them
together in forums so that they can get
to know each other understand how
difficult it is to be a police officer
understand how communities of color have
had to deal with unfair law enforcement
practices over the years you know bring
people together and it was through that
through those kinds of meetings that we
were able to formulate the policies that
ultimately led to the 21st century
proposals and then the other things that
we did you know bringing bringing
pattern and practice in investigations
using the power that we had under the
Civil Rights statutes that we were able
to able to enforce you know it was it
was from me
the highlight of my time as Attorney
General it was to given the opportunity
to get into communities to effect
positive change to bring and establish
relationships between again people in
law enforcement people in communities of
color that was I think in some ways you
know what I'm most proud of and it late
I think the foundation for future for
future work but I would always emphasize
this know the young people young people
that's our audience here today young
people were critically involved in all
of the work that we did starting at
Ferguson in other parts of the country I
want to ask you one more question before
I move on to our next speaker
you know I campaign 0 we believe we can
live in a world where the police don't
kill people so many of us are really
trying to engage Ratlam at
to imagine what our communities look
like like I said even beyond police even
looking at a moment where we don't even
have traditional systems because our
communities are so healthy from the
ground up when you think about your most
radical dream for what is possible your
most radical imagination for where we
can get to as a community and as a
people
what is that dream ooh that's an
interesting one you know I guess my my
dream is that we would get to a place
where people are judged on their their
individual deeds individual
characteristics and that we don't we
don't stereotype people and that you
know is not only with regard to how we
do with things in the criminal justice
system I think we have we make a mistake
if we think that the criminal justice
system exists separate and apart from
the greater society the issues that we
face in the criminal justice system
inappropriate uses of force implicit
bias whole range of things those grow
out of the same kinds of problems that
we see in the largest society and so
we've got a deal with problems you know
the more systemically more society-wide
if we want to actually deal and be
effective in bringing about needed
change which were brought to the
criminal justice system so you know I
would hope that we get to a place where
no discrimination is no longer a factor
in the lives of people of color that
fair treatment would be something that
would be would be expected stereotypes
you know born in slavery in the notion
that you know in order to enslave a
people it had to think that they were in
some ways different some ways inferior
and those attitudes may not be as
explicit as they once were but still or
a part I think of the American psyche
implicitly in radical change I'd like to
you know erase those those feelings in
base policy on you know on on real-world
experiences on on the reality of the
people of this nation as opposed to the
perceptions of a mysterio type some of
them
what I hear you are saying is that being
able to live being able to breathe not
having won anyone's foot on your neck
it's not actually a radical idea at all
that it is what everybody is owed thank
you so much
Attorney General Holder for joining us I
want to move now to Philippe Cunningham
who is a councilman from the city of
Minneapolis where so much of this is
centered Minneapolis is really ground
zero in so many ways as it was home to
George Floyd and his family Philippe I
have so many questions for you but first
I want to know how you're doing and what
is happening on the ground in
Minneapolis you know I see here on the
zoom call my friend Dion Jones who is
peacefully protesting in Los Angeles
when he was hit with the rubber bullet
we've seen so many images of that kind
of unnecessary confrontation and a lot
of them unfortunately are coming from
Minneapolis so how is home how is the
home team doing and what do we we
outside of Minneapolis need to
understand about what's going on on the
ground
yes well thank you so much for having me
thank you for that question I too just
want to start off with naming that I'm
here today because of the strength of my
ancestors and elders who came before me
finding the fight to make my existence
and work as an elected official possible
so on the ground in Minneapolis folks
are mobilizing on a scale we've never
seen before and a diverse coalition a
very diverse coalition of folks is
emerging demanding justice not only for
George Floyd but justice and how the
city of Minneapolis protects its
residents what we are seeing right now
from folks on the ground is in
Minneapolis and across the country is
generations of trauma and rage at the
violence bestowed on and on the black
community and the disinvestment of the
plat flak community by the state at
every single level of government and
I'll just add that I myself as a black
queer transgender man I to live
firsthand both with the trauma and the
trauma that I have to carry around
experiencing the wit and witnessing
state sanctioned violence as well as the
generational trauma
my ancestors who have survived slavery
so seeing all of this layering it on
what's interesting about the fact that
all of this has really been ground zero
in Minneapolis is that we are an
incredibly progressive progressive City
at the same time we are also the city
that has the most significant racial
disparities between white and black
folks in the entire country across every
indicator of quality of life so this has
just been boiling under the surface I've
been in office now for two and a half
years and within my first two years I
had to deal with three officer-involved
shooting deaths in my ward alone
including one that was a suicide-by-cop
the trauma from those from those
incidents doesn't just dissipate because
the legal system deems their deaths
justified the evidence is clear overall
President Obama spoke to the data that
we're starting to see over policing
criminalization and mass incarceration
have not kept our community safer in
fact people getting caught in the
criminal justice system further
disenfranchises black and brown folks
pushing us further to the margins of
society due to criminal histories thus
triggering a cycle of involvement with
crime in the criminal justice system
that is often passed intergenerationally
so what we're seeing on the ground in
Minneapolis is folks saying enough is
enough and our system is obviously
broken and it's time for a new system of
Public Safety in our city over the years
we have heard from folks who believe
that the solution is simply adding more
police officers and we've also heard
from folks who are reformers who want to
advocate for incremental change but even
those voices right now are waning
because our whole city has seen for the
past three nights that we have the
ability to keep ourselves safe in our
community safe so you ask how I'm doing
I'll say I'm a little bit tired because
I've been up all night with my community
organizing my community very closely
with folks on the ground to post-up
Patrol because Minneapolis Police apart
nor the National Guard we're showing up
to protect our homes and our small
businesses we're seeing large-scale
protests what those are seeing on the
media right now the protests and riots
in south Minneapolis we see that but in
North Minneapolis the historically black
community in Minneapolis where I
represent we've been dealing with our
right wing and white supremacist groups
terrorizing our community by burning
down black owned businesses so we've
come together protected our own
community and now it's time for us to
systematize community-led safety
strategies and make them sustainable so
how much thing you said and and couldn't
agree with you more on all of it a one a
hold space for the intersections of your
identities and the way that systems
particularly impact you and other folks
in your community because that's such a
critical part of the conversation and we
cannot allow it to be erased secondly I
want to acknowledge and agree with
everything you said about the fact that
we save us and we can continue to save
us the we can actually as I've been
saying imagine this beyond our
traditional systems and figure out how
we protect one another and how we build
up strong communities from the ground up
because we are more than capable no
matter what anyone else says so that's
actually what I really want to ask you
about because as an elected official you
are playing a role in a traditional
system but you're also having radical
imagination about what's possible
we know that budgets are moral documents
and we know that as we see some cities
investing more in policing they're
divesting from housing and jobs and the
things that keep people well and keep
their needs met so how are you thinking
about the demands that are coming
directly from grassroots activists and
enacting the most imaginative and bold
even though as we said earlier they
should just be the things that people
receive how are you thinking about
enacting those things and where does
Minneapolis have to go to ensure that
everybody there is not just living in a
liberal City but that they're living in
an equitable City that's right thank you
for for framing it that way so when I
talk about the work that needs to be
done what we have seen is that a lot of
reform efforts that have
been implemented we we had tremendous
leadership from our former mayor but
Minneapolis mayor Betsy Hodges who came
into office unabashedly demanding major
overhauls in the police
Minneapolis Police Department she
appointed the first woman chief police
chief who is also native and the first
LGBT police chief every officer was
trained in procedural justice and anti
bias training a Community Engagement
Team was created then she appointed our
first our city's first black police
chief chief Arredondo whose vision for
what's possible for policing is
inspiring and what we would all like to
see for policing but even with all of
that work many officers have been in all
but open revolt against these efforts
with their grievances being aired by the
Police Federation so when we take a step
back and look at the big picture about
what does it mean to keep our community
safe we have to be thinking about it
from a different frame a different
paradigm we know that the system of
policing is rooted it's founded on and
rooted in white supremacy in a history
of slave touching and so as we're trying
to do this work of reforming police
culture and instant institution of
policing overall we have to get serious
about investing in new alternative
systems of Public Safety that are rooted
in justice and our community we have a
paradigm for this it's the public health
approach to public safety so thinking
about violence as a disease that spreads
is a contagious disease it spreads
interpersonally and it spreads
intergenerationally and so there are
evidence-based strategies we and
Minneapolis have been working very
closely with John Jay College as well as
their national network for state
communities too as well as cities United
we've all been working together to
really is to to tional eyes this
opportunity I have been a tireless
advocate for violence prevention and
intervention efforts we created in late
2018 the office of violence provide
through city ordinance so now we can't
be taken away we institutionalized a new
system but that only goes so far we need
money to go into that and that's where
the budget is a moral document comes in
there's always political will to put
more money into the police budget the
police budget in Minneapolis is to
almost two hundred million dollars and
we have right now we approved last year
a budget of 1.6 billion dollars they
take up a huge chunk I had to fight
relentlessly to get $50,000 for a
domestic violence intervention program
strategy for us to implement despite the
fact that in Minneapolis the number one
reason for 911 ishi ated police calls
for service is because of domestic
assault
we are not successfully getting to the
roots of these issues so having a
systemic institutionalized new approach
to public safety that is community lead
that invests in community with the with
the the prevention and intervention as
well as thinking big even moving further
upstream thinking about housing jobs
employment training education thinking
about all of that that is what true
comprehensive Public Safety is and we
have to start thinking about what what
does it look like to have a future
without police what is it what would it
look like for us to not need police and
then work backwards from there I used to
be a teacher so backwards planning from
everything that is possible is my jam
that's my favorite thing to do and I'm
so glad that you really helped root us
in the concept of again radical
imagination and then action toward that
so obviously there are things that have
to happen in the short-term there are
policies that have to change their
investments that have to be made as you
move toward those long term goals but I
really want to as I close with you ask
you what should we all be understanding
those of us who do not live in
Minneapolis about what the grassroots
demands are
we are making our voices heard and
attempting to be supportive of what is
happening on the ground there what
should we be lifting up in the short
term the long term and everything in
between to get to that place of as you
said comprehensive community safety that
has to include not just policy but
culture and investment that's right well
first I'll just say I too was a teacher
I was a special education teacher on the
south side of Chicago so so the
backwards planning is a good thing so so
well what we really mean in terms of
support in Minneapolis is we just need
for folks to keep an eye on on us and to
be able to hold us accountable because
there is some real momentum here we like
I said we've heard since I've been in
office I've heard from so many folks who
are just like the only the way we solve
this problem is by just adding more
police if we just add more police that
will solve the problem
or if we implement these specific
reforms body cams diversifying the
police department anti-bias training
that sort of those sort of reforms then
we'll see the outcomes but we really
need to dig even deeper into it and what
we're seeing is a groundswell of demands
for the city of Minneapolis to defund
the police that's what we're seeing
right now these folks are the ones who
are transformation oriented and so the
in Minneapolis the public and political
will right now are very concentrated at
this point in transformational change
and things have also changed in that who
is in elected office here I'm actually
not the only black trans person on
Minneapolis City Council a lot of folks
don't realize that they're my sister
council vice-president Andrea Jenkins is
also on the Minneapolis City Council and
she's a powerhouse activists and
organizers have allies with the same
vision for equity and justice who are in
office now so that really opens the
possibility when we all work together so
I would say that where we're starting to
to dive into it the state's Minnesota
Department of Human Rights has opened an
investigation into the police department
for the last 10 years for systemic
racial discrimination so I would say
what we need right now is for folks
outside of Minneapolis to keep an eye on
what's going on and also to invest in
the folks the organizations who are on
the ground who've been doing this work
for years and years and to also push
folks on the ground here communities to
make their voices heard that is one of
the biggest things is that I hear the
most from the folks who just simply want
more police I have been labeled soft on
crime because of the fact that I
advocate for a comprehensive approach to
public safety so we need folks who
believe a transformational change in
what community safety can look like and
how to get there
we need for folks voices to be heard
we've already begun to see the seeds of
so much of that transformation right
there in your hometown due to leadership
of yours and so many others we saw the
first black woman student body president
at the University of Minnesota get them
to stop contracting with the police
force there we saw that the public
schools there followed suit and from
former teacher a former teacher I'm
always like yes it's about time that we
actually make schools safe for all young
people and that doesn't need to include
police so thank you so much not just for
this conversation before your continued
courage and action in the role that
you're playing I'm going to come lastly
to my good friend and partner in this
work Rashad Robinson who is the
president of Color of Change Rashad
we've been on the phone a lot in the
last few weeks and you are always
thinking so critically about how we
ensure that the local conversations that
councilman Cunningham just talked about
are really upheld at the national level
and that everyone is doing their part as
I always say we don't have saviors we
build teams and that's how we get the
work done in community and that's
exactly the work that color have change
does it gives all of us an opportunity
to be on the team so how are you
thinking about making sure that people
understand what their role is on the
team what are the spectrum of demands
that you are seeing coming from your
members at Color of Change and that you
all are exploring and pushing as you do
this work well thank you first of all
Thank You Bernie for that question and
thank you President Obama and Attorney
General Holder and it's actually great
to be on this conversation and to be
back doing work with my brother's keeper
what I will say is a couple of things
you know over the last eight months just
alone over five million people have
taken action with Color of Change
raising their voices online signing
petitions making phone calls showing up
to rallies and that's important right
because what we want to be able to do is
translate the presence of this moment
into the ability to actually change the
rules and sometimes those are the
written rules of policy and other times
those are the written unwritten rules of
culture and I want to talk about both
about my both of those things are
critically important in this moment and
why do we have to channel strategic
action to actually get things done no
individual alone is going to work to
change systemic racism in all the ways
that it impacts our society racism is
like water pouring over a floor with
holes in it it will find the cracks and
so we constantly need to figure out how
are we showing up the systems that will
have cracks in them and building new
systems for the future and so on the
written rule side we are very much
focused on on how do you give people in
that moment something clear to do
pushing for justice and when justice
needs to be served but working
recognizing that we gotta move people up
a ladder of engagement because none of
the families simply want justice for
their own family they recognize that the
long term rules need to change and what
comes to policing there is so much that
happens at the local level that we have
to pay attention to the other speakers
talked about it and so we need to be
focusing that energy on local policy
pushing to change local practice and the
difference between policy and practices
sometimes we change the law but we also
have to change the people who implement
those laws and then we think about the
work at the federal level and we've got
to change all of the ways in which money
from the federal level incentivizes
indecent disincentivizes certain types
of action and part of what we try to do
with color change is point people at
those strategic things to do building
sort of the energy and helping to
describe for people how to do it you
know a couple of years ago in the height
of the of the work to you know channel
challenge of police violence we came up
against district attorneys and state's
attorneys that we simply did not have
the ability to move we would show up it
didn't matter if we had ten petitions or
ten thousand petitions or a hundred
thousand petitions they were not nervous
about disappointing our community and so
we recognized we had to help the
community better understand the role of
district attorney together build more
energy because district attorneys
couldn't operate without public pressure
these are executive level positions that
can have a large amount the sort of most
powerful actors in the criminal justice
space so we built the only searchable
national database of prosecutors in the
country called written justice door we
worked with folks in Hollywood like
comment to develop a animated video that
describes the role of district attorneys
for everyday people so people can
understand how District Attorney's
operate we work across the movement to
get folks from big organization to local
grassroots organizations aligned around
six clear demands that we could take to
get people talking about treating kids
as kids on reducing and ending the use
of money bail I'm changing sort of
reducing the increasing transparency all
of these things are incredibly important
to sort of winning justice long-term
right we have to change the role of
prosecutor and he have to change what
the public expects from prosecutors we
have to change the way that the public
thinks about criminal justice and that
kind of leads me to the cultural
conversation because for the last 20
years for the last 20 years basically
kind of with a couple of blips here and
there violent crime has steadily went
down in our country but according to Pew
and everyone else Americans think that
violent crime is going up and so we have
a deep gap between perception and
reality and that makes it much harder we
are trying to do those critical things
that the councilman talked about in
terms of reducing police budgets in
terms of actually ensuring that we're
investing in education and mental health
and jobs and all the things that we know
that communities that have had reduced
the need for law enforcement they don't
need as many police and so because the
public has been inundated with images
that makes us believe that violent crime
is right around the window right around
the door we've had to build a program
and through our work at change Hollywood
org through our efforts we work with USC
to do a whole study of crime TV shows
and now we're working in writers rooms
to push and change the content and the
storytelling so one of the things that
we looked at was all of these crime TV
shows that are covered in cities like
Chicago in New York very diverse on-air
and if you look at the writers rooms and
all the writers rooms are all white
folks with no sort of connects you to
the community no skin in the game on
sort of the impact of the images that
they're portraying constantly putting a
sort of black faces on the criminal
justice system of a sort of magical
world where black and brown people exist
but racism doesn't and we have to really
work to sort of change that and part of
that activism is the work that we have
to do because if we're going to get to
the place where the narrative changes
enough for us to achieve the type of
policy changes that are needed we have
to change the story
and I want to say that far too often we
tell a story about black communities
being vulnerable and we'll say things
like black communities are vulnerable
with black communities have been under
attack black community
targeted black communities have had a
history of being of being fleece of
being under invested and all of those
things are not about being vulnerable
those are things about being on the
chopping block and so what we work to
change that story we can accomplish so
much more I have one very brief question
for you because I know we have to wrap
up now people keep asking me this
question so I want to ask you and maybe
you can give me some tips is this moment
a game-changer we've been in this work
for a while now many will have been in
it for even longer than us but is this
moment a seismic shift in what's
possible where we see ourselves right
now you know I think it's a great
question because I think that we we want
fast food we want things that are quick
and we want things that are easy and
progress and justice is not easy right
the thing about inflection points is
that they present the possibility for a
huge leaps forward or they actually
present the real threat for us to go
backwards and I think what we all have
to recognize is that a lot of things
actually have changed over the last
several years what people in a Starbucks
take out their cell phone and are
filming on the police interaction that
they don't actually that they recognize
is wrong because a movement has built
the sort of mental model to train them a
major financial company when they create
consequences for an employee that does
something racist in a park uses the word
racism in their statement in a way that
we probably wouldn't imagine them doing
that doesn't mean we give institutions
too much credit but we recognize what we
have won along the way and them in the
way in which we have shifted what our
demands can be we shifted what can be
possible and so I want folks to think
that we have been the game changer the
game has continued to change and the
deep level of pushback that we can
continue to get from forces is an
absolute result of the power that our
movement is building make no mistake it
doesn't mean that progress is
but I want us to I want folks who are
coming into this movement to not come
into this movement thinking that they've
got a fixer movement but that they've
got to like put on their armor and join
us they've got to follow the
institutions that have been driving and
making so much change and then they've
gotta add their creativity and their
interest to what we are doing but we
have been winning and so much of the
reaction to what we are seeing is a
result of the progress that I believe we
are making precisely the pushback
wouldn't be so great if the progress
wasn't real and we are the game-changer
Rashaad thank you so much you know we've
heard in this conversation that social
change work changing our communities
having the kind of world we deserve it's
hard work but it is absolutely necessary
work and we have to be brave enough to
imagine what is possible and then go
work for it and not just dream it and we
also have to be incisive enough to make
sure that people are safe and whole and
healthy now look black people deserve to
live because we are human and black
people deserve much more from America
for lots of reasons but in part because
we often save it from itself we know for
sure that we don't just deserve to
survive we deserve to thrive that means
we need justice and as dr. Cornel West
says justice is what love looks like in
public so let's go make sure that love
is living out loud in public mr.
president I see your face I've seen that
face many times before in our meetings I
know you are itching to ask a question
so I will close and hand it off to you
well I've just been enjoying you know
hearing all the wisdom that's been
spread but by so many others I want to
first of all give Eric Holder his props
as Attorney General he rebuilt a Civil
Rights Division within the Justice
Department and was consistently on the
ground working with communities
listening to communities and coming up
with practical solutions to try to make
things better
and I couldn't be prouder of him blown
away by Philippe and all the good work
that he's doing you rashad has been a
consistent warrior for change you know
he was part of the conversations we had
after Ferguson and and Brittany you know
you know I think you you're all that so
so so as I listen I am feeling once
again inspire and what has particularly
inspired me is the degree to which folks
are thinking strategically practically
at a very detailed level about where are
the places where you can make change and
what are the practical solutions backed
up by research backed up by data backed
up by experience that allows us to
create a set of communities that are
safe and just safe and fair safe and
non-discriminatory and that is possible
and and I think that one of the things
that has been raised is the fact that we
don't have the capacity to eradicate 400
years of racism and one fell swoop so if
we think that this is a seismic shift I
hope people don't feel like well
nothing's going to happen once we figure
this out you know as I've been known to
quote dr. King I've said frequently
yeah the arc of the moral universe is
long but it bends towards justice we
Bend it all of you have bent it over the
last four or five six ten years and we
are seeing the fruits of those laborers
in the degree of awareness that is out
there look at me think about some of the
people who have unequivocally spoken out
again
what happened in many actors I mean you
have I just saw Jim heart bother so I
know we got you know the Ohio State
contingent here but you got Jim our
brother that the the coach of Michigan
football marshal today that's not
something that was happening five six
years ago although Jim I know and he's
been on the right side of this issue for
quite some time
you have unlikely participants because
all of you have worked so hard to raise
awareness that's the that's that's the
progress that has been made it doesn't
mean everything's been solved the only
question I think maybe might be
worthwhile for me to throw out there
even though I've read enough at
literature to have a pretty good sense
of what the answer is going to be
wouldn't Britney you mentioned that you
campaign zero is put forward eight can't
wait we talked about the 21st century
task force report it'd be useful maybe
just tick off very quickly what are the
things that are they that that campaign
zeros is promoting because for a lot of
people who are watching they may be
surprised but some of these things are
practical and could be implemented
quickly I know just to just one off the
top of my head that I know we can all
focus on because it's been so painfully
real these last few weeks
choke holds and strangleholds just
saying that's not what we do you don't
need that in order to effectively
restrain someone so so give me give me
what what are they in an executive
summary form so people can get here what
these specific things are
got you so I didn't the first question
would come to me but the a things are
banning chokeholds in strangleholds
requiring de-escalation first requiring
a warning before pulling out a weapon
exhausting all alternatives for those
actions a duty of other officers to
intervene so officers can just stand
there and watch injustice happen
banning shooting at moving vehicle you
know keeps he's an everyday citizen safe
establishing a use of force Qian and
requiring all force to be reported and I
want to be really clear together those
eight things can reduce police violence
but upward seventy percent that does not
stand in competition with what Philippe
just walked us through because we know
that these things can happen immediately
with any executive order or act of
Congress all we need is a mayor to have
the political will and courage to stamp
and say those ain't can't wait and I
will go and change Yusef or standard
night let alone tomorrow so do that now
and then continue to work with your
community because we will continue to
keep up the pressure I can promise you
that to make sure that we are getting to
those comprehensive public safety
solutions that are community based and
community oriented and far beyond
anything that we're experiencing right
now that Philippe just walked us through
these don't stand in competition with
imagination these are a necessary step
immediately to keep people safe as we do
the hard work of making sure we get
what's that's great and and and let me
just point out in my opening remarks I
mentioned sometimes this tension is
posed between political participation
and protest police an example of why you
have to participate politically because
if you are on the streets protesting and
making demands having somebody on the
City Council who can follow up and
respond and advocate and and deal with
pushback and is in the room when budgets
are made and
is advising mayor's on how they're going
to negotiate the next collective
bargaining contract with the police
union you need those folks in order to
ultimately deliver the goods and and you
know I'm constantly mindful of the fact
that this is not a an either/or thing
and there's so many ways all of which
are necessary to make a difference when
Rashad talked about the cultural element
of this you know dr. King this may be
apocryphal but but I think somebody
mentioned to him well you know just
having a anti-discrimination bill is an
anti-lynching bill you know that's not
gonna change hearts and minds he says no
won't but it'll maybe stop me from
getting lynched and that's important too
okay so laws are important on the other
hand the narrative and the stories and
telling people here you see me on human
here's my pain this is somebody's son
this is somebody's uncle here's the
story that you need to understand about
our background in our community how do
we break down stereotypes as area Eric
Holder eloquently talked about that's
the work of a lot of people you know so
some are gonna be on the streets
protesting some are gonna be running for
us
some are gonna be writing I during this
week I picked up and reread the fire
next time it is frightening to notice
how James Baldwin can lay out a reality
50 years ago that sounds like it was
written yesterday and that's activism
that's work that's participation so so I
worry sometimes that you know as we
debate strategies people start thinking
there's one way of doing things we all
have a role to play we all have a part
the more specific we are practical you
know in the short term
as well as visionary in the long term
the better off we're going to be
with that I'm gonna be quiet because you
don't need to hear from more more old
head stuff but I just want to say how
much I appreciate all of you and and
Michael I'm assuming that the
conversation is going to continue yes
sir let me go ahead and jump in and
thank Britney for the masterful
moderation and for all the wisdom and
hard work that was on display I'm now
going to turn it over to our deputy
director for network and partnerships at
my brother's keeper Alliance on the coal
fields who's going to take a couple
questions from our MBK communities so
not everyone watching has an opportunity
to ask questions but our MBK communities
do so that's another reason you should
become an advocate community so Nicole
is gonna pose a couple questions but we
will get you out of here by 6:30
everyone we realize that we've been on
for a while but we will be sending
resources afterwards we've also created
a Google group so we can continue this
conversation there as well
so Nicole let me bring you on to field
those questions
thank you Michael Thank You Brittany
Thank You President Obama really
powerful conversation tons of great
questions as Michael mentioned we can
continue this conversation so if we
don't get to your question do not worry
we can't contain this conversation or
Google group I'm gonna take the first
question from our young people play on
Patrick asks this question is directed
at councilman Cunningham how have the
media's portrayal of frequent violent
riots in Minneapolis affected your
efforts to promote the work of
protesters activists and elected
officials pushing towards a
self-sustaining public safety system yes
thank you for that question play town so
play on excuse me so the media's
portrayal of focusing hyper focusing on
the violent protests or the violence and
the rioting happening during the
protests really pulls away from what is
actually happening the real story of the
trauma and the pain and the reason why
folks are out on the ground doing the
work why we are traumatized as a
community why we are doing this work
together so the media is looking for a
sensational story and talking about the
public health approach to public safety
is not that sexy
so it's easier to be able to pick the
what's happening right now
make that newsworthy and so what it does
is it's distracting it's distracting
from the voice of the folks who are on
the community who have demands who have
a clear vision it's distracting it's
pulling away from their voice and
centering them the folks have been on
the ground non-stop for years some it's
some folks in their cases for decades
and so I want to make sure that I've
been all over the media I've been
fortunate that folks have been reaching
out all over the world and I keep
hammering home everybody wants to talk
about the the riots and you know the
violence and and you know everything
that's happening but I always redirect
it back to it is possible for us to
build alternative systems to public
safety outside of policing it requires
political will it requires investment
and we are already doing it and it works
and so trying to constantly bring it
back to that is really what I think it's
important that we have messengers who
have the platforms the bully pulpits as
we say a politics have those platforms
to be able to speak that we have to keep
pushing it and not let media distract us
from really the point which is justice
Thank You councilmember great well said
the next question actually was asked a
few folks acts the same exact question
and I think any one of our panelists can
take this what advice can you give to
mayor's to honor protesters demands for
more police accountability and less
brutal and racist practices while
supporting their police force and
maintaining broad public confidence
folks have been asking how do we change
these accountability measures while also
confronting police unions who have
invested in our elected officials you
know I'm gonna take a stab at something
just because I think it's the last
forgiving
it doesn't answer the entire question
when I was in the state legislature it
back in Illinois we passed one of the
first if not the first laws dealing with
racial profiling and traffic stops and
there was no way to get that passed
without support of the FOP the Fraternal
Order of Police the primary organization
of the police unions and the argument I
was able to make to them was that police
officers are going to be safer if there
is greater trust and less tension that
they will be able to do their jobs
better if they have data that has been
collected that is clear and police
chief's are going to be able to manage
their forces more effectively they will
be less distracted by things that don't
require an armed response and they can
refocus attention in in in ways that are
good for them as well as the community
and it took a long time to make that
argument and I'm sure that there are
rank-and-file members who didn't believe
it but in fact after we passed it we
started being able to collect data on
that issue and we were able to get them
to go along now how responsive the
police unions gonna be in any
circumstance yeah it's gonna go city by
city and and and it's not easy but I
guess the point I am making and Eric
Holder if he's still on
want to chime in on this I do think
there is police leadership that
recognizes the need for change but
changing culture is hard and sometimes
the dynamics within the union's
themselves are difficult and you know
and sometimes there's that sense of we
need to close ranks even though we know
some things are messed up and so finding
ways to listen and and recognize that
they have a tough job but also then
insist that this is what we need to do
we're going to do it we'll work with you
to figure out how to do it so when
Brittany talked about the a can't wait
you should have a dialogue to find out
what specific things are a problem with
not having to choke somebody
particularly when they're already in
handcuffs yeah what is it that you think
is a problem i when you force people to
articulate what it is that they object
to with reasonable demands of the sort
that have been outlined a lot of times
they come up empty but you have to
engage in that conversation and I think
that it's it's possible to get that done
at the end of the day though if you
don't have the political pressure to do
it they will resist just because social
yep the status will always resists
without some pressure and that's why
it's so important both for the protests
and for the follow-up that people like
councilman Cunningham can apply great
Thank You President Obama next question
let's stick to more this question is
coming from dr. Jim Bostick in Yonkers
New York firstly thanks our panelists
and says his question is how do we
effectively integrate the generational
differences in age and history often see
develop between our younger generation
and those of us who have been in this
fight for many decades in such a way
that we respect each other's ideas and
approaches to dealing with institutional
racism in our risk
active communities and not diminish the
role and the will of either so I'm gonna
say I'm gonna have to call call it here
this will have to be the last question
and I'm gonna ask one of our panelists
to take that and and try to give us the
90 second response while you're thinking
of your spots I just want to say how
grateful we are for dr. Jim Bostick
Yonkers is one of our MBK impact
communities that is doing extraordinary
where you work on the ground in Yonkers
and in the and the prison system in
Yonkers as well so who'd like to take
that question
with with a quick response well I'd say
this you know there is the need for
young people to work with people like
myself who are who have some years
behind them and the arrogance of youth
cannot be the determinant the arrogance
of of age can't be a determinant there
is wisdom through lived experience
there's idealism that young people
possess in abundance and it's a
combination of that idealism with that
experience that I think makes the most
effective movements people who are older
have to understand that young people
have always been at the forefront of
positive change in this nation when the
founding fathers were really young
people the oldest Federalist was George
Washington's only 44 years old and you
know Richard Pryor used to say that you
don't see many old fools and so I think
young people need to understand that as
well you know there is you don't get to
be 60 70 80 years old without having
navigated a whole series of things
that's worthwhile and you have things as
a young person you might want to test
theories you want to try older people
can say well I've experienced this and
this is why this theory is not going to
work so it's a combination of the two
and a lack of arrogance on the part of
both that ultimately can create a
coalition that can be successful Thank
You mr. Attorney General mr. president
before we wrap up any final words now
okay just keep working and and and stay
hopeful as I said this is a moment and
we've had moments like this before where
people
all are paying attention and that
doesn't mean that everything will get
soft and so don't get dissing harden
because there's a marathon not a sprint
but the fact that people are paying
attention provides an opportunity to
educate activate mobilize and act and I
hope that we are able to seize this
moment I hope the mayors across the
country who have either been watching or
hear about this take that pledge to
start immediately implementing some
steps that can make a difference and I
hope all the young people who've been
inspired and engaged and involved they
keep at it because that's what
ultimately is gonna create the kind of
country we want as and for those who are
have been talking about protesters just
remember this country was founded on
protest it is called the American
Revolution and every step of progress in
this country every expansion of freedom
every expression of our deepest ideals
has been won through efforts that made
the status quo uncomfortable and and
then we should all be thankful for folks
who are willing in a peaceful
disciplined way to be out there making a
difference so thank you so much
everybody proud of it
Thank You mr. president I encourage all
of you to go to Obama or go to Obama or
if you're mayor take the pledge if
you're looking to become an NBA
community if you're looking for places
to donate or resources or just to join
the alliance going to Obama org we will
continue to be there for with you with
you our partners at the Leadership
Conference mayor's are excited to
provide technical assistance for you as
you think about reading those use of
force policies as well as our broader
partner network so this is just the
beginning of a conversation will
continue this in many different ways and
also be on the lookout for our
next town hall that will be coming up as
well as some other actions Thank You mr.
president
Thank You mr. Attorney General Thank You
councilman Cunningham Thank You Brittany
Thank You Rashad Robinson thank you to
all of our MBK communities for the
extraordinary work you do every day on
behalf of our boys and young men of
color and our sisters and thank you to
all of our young men and all of our
young women for everything that you do
not just to be the future but to be the
change today have a great day everybody
it's in the vicinity of the space
station and it's actually the space
station so that was a huge learning
curve er we human-rated a spacecraft for
a portion of the mission and then four
crew you just have to obviously expand
it for the whole mission and then the
last part was cargo dragon has been this
amazing tech bed for Commercial Crew and
what that means is we were able to test
out like